new at 11 a local rescue is trying to  find the person who left a box of  newborn puppies in a dumpster southern  nevada animal rescue league or snarl  says somebody reached out to them this  week asking for help  nine puppies were founded a north las  vegas apartment complex rescue leaders  want to remind everyone that there are  resources available and there's no  reason to ever just abandon an animal  there's so many options out there  for  people to reach out and  um  like reach out to rescues the animal  foundation  for someone else to take care of these  puppies and if we could find mom that  would be great then mom could be  reunited with her babies  yeah these babies were barely a week old  the puppies appear to be pit bull mixes  they are with the foster dog though who  recently had puppies and she's still  able to feed them if you have any  information about where they may have  come from please contact the southern  nevada animal rescue league